[Music]
it's feeding time
what surprisingly this isn't the most
terrifying thing in this film hey
everyone I just watched Artemis Fowl and
it was Artemis Fowl oh god yes Disney
has pulled a Netflix and dumped an
absolute stinker of an original
currently sitting at 3.7 on IMDB my mind
is still processing what I just watched
now if you've been around my channel
before or like and subscribe if you
haven't you'll know I'd like to take
popular shows and films with terrible
endings and rewrite them but Artemis
Fowl deserves a complete rewrite like
page one so in this video I'm gonna
outline what made this film so bad and
ways to go about fixing it disclaimer I
have not read the Artemis Fowl books so
this video will just be focusing on plot
points in the movie first things first
Artemis Fowl is an adaptation and
adaptations are notoriously tough to
write how do you remain faithful to a
book while simultaneously trying to tell
its story within the medium of an
hour-and-a-half movie I mean if we
literally tried to fit all of Lord of
the Rings in a movie 80% of it would be
descriptions of landscapes and the snow
flowed down with adaptations you have to
be able to adapt that means cutting or
adding characters moving scenes around
or completely adding new scenes in order
to make the story fit the medium of film
so that being said let's get into my
first point the beginning beginnings are
arguably the most important part of a
movie they set up the characters bring
us into their world and tell us what the
story is really about in a world where
there's so much TV and movie options if
we aren't hooked in the first few
minutes people will just move on to the
next thing in this section I'm gonna
focus on the first 10 minutes and
Artemis Fowl has a terrible beginning
that squanders those few precious
opening minutes the first 3 minutes and
45 seconds are all about how the world
is searching for Artemis Fowl senior
he's wanted in connection with a bunch
of world famous treasures which have
gone missing 3 minutes and 45
seconds are wasted on a plot point that
has almost no bearing on the overall
story we don't even find out what
happened to these artifacts at the end
of the movie the next minute and 15
seconds our shots of our protagonist
Artemis Fowl jr. surfing again this
doesn't advance the plot at all nor does
it set up anything about the character
that pays off later I thought for sure
there would be a scene later on in the
film where he has to get on some sort of
surfing device and utilize this skill
but nope this entire waste of precious
time has no payoff later in the film the
next two minutes involve a meeting with
Artemis and his therapist dr. Poe a
character who is completely
inconsequential and who will never see
again the point of this scene is twofold
to show that Artemis is an arrogant
know-it-all and for us the viewer to
understand what his major character flaw
is the problem is that I know the
textbook reply to any question you may
choose to ask the problem is that you
don't respect anyone enough to treat
them as an equal but by having dr. Poe
tell us this the movie is going against
one of the basic rules of screenwriting
show don't tell we the viewer nor
artemis the character should be told
what his flaw is we want to see it so
what if I told you to scrap these first
10 minutes altogether and we could
create a scene that tells us all about
who Artemis is as a character while
simultaneously moving the plot forward
and making us care about him now just be
warned I came up with this in like 10
minutes and these Disney writers have
many months so bear with me if you think
it's not up to snuff
I'd start right off the bat with Artemis
at school it's a huge science fair and
Artemis has with him a giant robot Lego
thing that's clearly superior to those
of his classmates we've seen in the
actual movie that Artemis is really into
this stuff and it also sets him up as
being brilliant he goes around telling
the other kids how they could have made
improvements to their projects but he
just comes off as arrogant and a
know-it-all this ticks off some of the
other students who bully him pushing him
into his giant project completely
shattering it to pieces as his fellow
classmates stand around and laugh at him
this entire scene is pretty basic and
can run about a minute and a half but it
accomplishes everything and more than
the actual version did in 10 we now
understand that Artemis
smart good at building and innovation we
see his flaw is his arrogance and that
he's alone and has no friends I'm now
more invested in him as a character
because I feel his pain I empathize with
him and best of all this is all done
through showing not telling the first
few minutes is all about setting up our
protagonists character arc so that over
the course of this journey we'll see him
change from an arrogant know-it-all who
is picked on at school to a humble hero
with the courage to take on the bad guys
the next scene could be dr. Poe or the
principal trying to get in touch with
Artemis's father after this bullying
incident but he's not around
in fact Artemis senior is almost never
there and this leads me to my second big
rewrite note there's almost no character
development between the characters when
you have no development between the
characters you get scenes which lack an
emotional punch or just plain don't make
sense
for example 3/4 of the way through the
movie Artemis's Butler doe Malloy is
killed
aside from training we never see Artemis
in him have a real moment together what
makes their bond so special was he
around when his father wasn't making him
kind of a pseudo father-like figure to
him imagine how much more powerful this
scene would be if we truly felt how much
Dom's death would mean to Artemis how
special their connection was another
example is the relationship between the
fairy Holly Short and Artemis are we
friends
Artemis Fowl we are forever friends
this scene is completely hollow because
we haven't seen these two become friends
they haven't bonded at all in fact
Artemis has kept Holly trapped in his
home for three quarters of the movie as
his prisoner note number three the
villain is terrible and boring there's
not much we know about the villain known
as OPA local boy other than she's a
brilliant bad fairy who wants revenge at
least I think it's sushi the entire
movie all she does is brood in her lair
she basically does nothing the entire
film the best villains are ones that
think they're not evil that they're the
ones in the right her motivation is just
revenge so I'd write her to be more
proactive and give her some sort of
personal motivation to justify her want
to take over the world
maybe her family was killed by humans
and she believes that fairy's taking
over would result in a more peaceful
world but the fact her face is hidden
the entire time and again I haven't read
the books leads me to believe she is
likely Artemis's mother hence why they
have to hide it note number four what
the hell is the Accu loss it takes 36
minutes for us to find out what this
thing is
the fairies wanted the villain wants it
Artemis wants it but for much of the
movie I don't even know what it does the
first mention of its power comes after
that 36 minute point and we find out
it's an object of unimaginable that can
give its wielder the greatest spells in
fairy lore and the ability to teleport
whole armies and wipe out life that
detail should have been explained way
earlier as it would give Holly and the
fairies huge stakes and motivation to
find it if they don't it could mean the
destruction of humanity and if the wrong
person gets their hands on it who knows
what unimaginable calamities could
happen note number 5 set up and payoff
as I previously stated with Artemis's
surfing which was never paid off there
are many instances where things aren't
set up for example Artemis talks about
how his dad used to recite this Irish
blessing this comes up several times
throughout the film
like when Artemis deduces that his
father's secret journal is hiding in a
book that contains this blessing and
later when Artemis recites it to a dying
doma boy we should have seen Artemis's
father recite this to him if it's that
important instead it's an
other instance of telling us instead of
showing us another example of a payoff
with no setup happens around the end of
the film when Artemus talks to the
villain just who do you think you are
I'm Artemis Fowl
and I'm a criminal mastermind a criminal
mastermind I don't think I've seen this
character do one criminal thing this
entire film I mean I guess you could say
he locked up Holly but he was doing that
for good reasons note number six
irrelevant characters remember Juliette
doma voice nice you could take her out
of the story and literally nothing would
change having extra characters just
muddies everything and all Juliette does
is give people meals and quip a sentence
here and there the fact that she's Dom's
niece also has no bearing on the story
whatsoever
then there's Breyer cousin we first see
him in jail and somehow opal has the
power to get him out and he's suddenly
in a higher position than the commander
he apparently reports to some sort of
executive branch but we never see them
and we also never learn how he got in
jail in the first place and how no one
questions how he got back I think he
could take this character out and not
much of this story would change Note
number seven mulch dig UM's other than
the absolutely terrifying CGI of him
dislocating his jaw mulches character
isn't that relatable because it takes us
too long to establish a connection with
him a whopping 55 minutes into the film
he says this this should have been
expressed crystal clear in the first
scene with him yeah we see him in line
with his quote-unquote own people and
learn how he's different from them but
we don't get a sense that he wants to be
like them if mulch wants to be short his
character arcs should be that by the end
of the film he realizes that his size
makes him unique and that he ultimately
embraces what made him different and he
kind of does this in one extreme wide
shot which seems like a line added in
post
yes he just kinda yells dwarfish
giganticus and that's all we really get
a mark of a good story is seeing
characters with a flaw go through a
journey and change because of it and I
didn't get that feeling with any of the
characters these setups often didn't
have any payoffs or the payoffs didn't
have any setups so there isn't any magic
solution that will save this movie we
can't simply move a scene around or
change some dialogue since this film has
so many problems as I stated in the
beginning this is a page-one rewrite but
what we can do is identify its problems
and build from it we establish our
characters flaws so we can see how they
grow throughout the film make sure they
develop deep emotional connections with
one another have a villain whose
motivations are deeper and that actually
does something to get what they want so
Disney I'm here baby I'm really cheap
I'll give your script to read and even
toss in a free things story mug that's
as much as I can talk about Artemis Fowl
before my brain explodes but thank you
for watching make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and for more bat takes follow
me on twitter at dings story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much